when you guys first started because you
guys were also doing the jabberwocky
faceless mass thing were there a lot of
comparisons
to that crew and like how did it make
you guys feel when you guys were trying
to do your own thing and they were
comparing you to somebody else
yeah um i have a i have a totally unique
relationship with that
yeah that's a great question because uh
i feel like a lot of people on
interwebs like to like do their thing
and personally i don't really care too
much
people do what they do you know what i'm
saying um and
you experience what you experience but
for me i have a really unique
relationship because like if none of my
guys in the crew
were ever a part of that organization
sure it'd be like oh man we're trying to
do our thing
right but like in my crew there's in
five four three two one hola everybody
oh nihao we have a very very special
guest
we have the very kenja himself
anthony [ __ ] lee do i do people
look to camera do people do that you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
this is a podcast jacket
i want to cross-eyed so i can like see
both the audiences i haven't seen you
in [ __ ] forever it's been a long time
man it's because uh you know uh
one i was gone forever so i wasn't doing
jk and by the time i came back this year
aka couldn't
do anything but things like jk you know
you were already gone
yeah what you that's right i stopped
doing jk news yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i mean that was like
the most regular that i would see you
yeah and then i was always sprayed
because i was always out traveling or
going to china or whatnot
well because you guys have the uh you
guys have a studio out there right or
you have multiple studios yeah we got
three studios out in china
um everything got shut down during covid
by the way uh and now
we're back yeah they're they're open now
but they're like 20 capacity so you know
things are a little bit tough but
other than that you know uh because i
couldn't travel anymore so i was at home
so i finally hit up like
you know bart and just like yo i'm
actually here maybe i should like come
through more
more often so that's why i've been
actually regularly doing jk news now
but then you've been gone yeah i haven't
been back uh i stopped doing jk news
probably it's been almost two years now
yeah yeah so i stopped doing jk news
like that platform
it was like a weird spot for me because
i think we've been i've been doing it
for so long we do it for like 10 years
you know and it's not my company so yeah
at the end of the day for me it was like
i wanted to do other things and they you
know they already knew that but it was a
weird time for me to
leave the company because there was
nobody to fill my space so
that was like a good cast chemistry that
we had and then when uh
steve started coming in that's when i
was like oh i actually have a out
you mean a big dude a big dude who was
gonna say whatever the [ __ ] he wanted
exactly there's somebody that needs to
be there and uh there was times that i
would leave
to do projects whether i was on a show
and i would be gone like a month at a
time maybe two three weeks at a time
and you know like tiff would text me she
goes hey like we really need you back
like the chemistry's a little off
so i would come back and you know the
show was real fun um but at the end of
the day i wanted to do other things you
provide great chemistry on there man
it's always fun to dance with you
because you always give us something to
talk about
yeah i think that's what we needed that
one person for
you know but then after i left i think
it's true once once you leave people
have to adjust
so they they adjusted perfectly fine and
steve does a [ __ ] great job so
i decided to leave and then uh it was
kind of weird for me because
i had to figure out what my next step
was because when you do stuff
consistently it just becomes
you know very comfortable yeah and so
you get you get
really set into this comfort and then
you're like okay you're not thinking
about next moves
because what you have makes money it's
fun you're hanging out with your friends
all day
but then after a while because you're so
content in that
you don't really think about your next
steps so i was like okay if i cut this
out i had to think about my next steps
and so
did the podcast that's [ __ ] great
right here man
cheers dude that's what it is you're
going out i feel that you feel that cup
again
can you fill me up [ __ ] i'm all getting
warm
let's talk about you though man [ __ ] me
dude
we can make that happen too but um so
for you
i mean obviously you're a dancer but i
don't think i've ever gotten to know you
in the sense of how you started in dance
where you started where you grew up or
anything like that so let's let's start
from the the bare bones because i think
people do want to get to know you number
one
how did you even get into dancing in the
first place
oh man okay i got my cliche answer and
then i'll go into like the details that
might be juicy and fun
for conversations because i feel like
i've gone over the story many times but
in many different platforms
yeah you do this in like a college
seminar then you do this on like an
online talk show
and then you get into a podcast where
you know that the person that you're
talking to don't really give a [ __ ]
about just like regular [ __ ] so you can
kind of say like real real [ __ ]
so i'm gonna embrace that uh unique
portal
one michael jackson easy saw that [ __ ]
on tv
this fool is [ __ ] crazy he's doing
the illest things known to man
all you want to do is try to emulate him
his music's sick
easy peasy but at the time in my high
school
if you were to dance like it was kind of
gay right
yeah that's literally that was really
the mentality i remember
uh the dance production at sunny hills
high school shout out to sunny hills
and there was all these chicks that were
in the dance productions i was one dude
so one dude was very i'm not gonna judge
him but he was very
flamboyant yeah yeah yeah so naturally
from a high school
dumbass ignorant perspective you're like
damn i kind of want to dance but
if i do everybody's going to think i'm
gay
right that's such a like a 90s mentality
but that's exactly what it was
you did anything in the arts in the
early 90s people just immediately
assumed you liked dick
yeah that was it he was like ah he's
dancing he clearly likes penis and
that's just how it was so i avoided it
yeah i started before i picked up like
guitar
which was great you know i tried to do
other things but i like avoided i saw
like
filipinos crumping in the corner and the
only thing because i didn't know
anything about it i would be like haha
that's so weird because krumping was
like a brand new thing at the time
yeah but i didn't let myself get into it
finally i go to college
and in college you suddenly see these
giant dance teams like cadc was one of
the first ones i saw
and you just see like you know when
you're an incoming freshman you see
college girls dancing you're just like
i don't know anything about you but
you're fine yeah you want to join that
club
yeah and then you see dudes dancing next
to them but they're not necessarily
dancing in like what you had in your
ignorant naive stereotype of being like
gay you know um so at that time
you just see these college chicks and
you're like i have to join this club so
suddenly it like changes
this is this is the bare bones like
version of like what most people who get
into dance
that are dudes like i guarantee you a
lot of people always say the same
journey like behind closed doors it's
like why did you first start dancing to
impress girls period
i bit someone i had been on here right
did you say the same thing
i literally told them like i hate it
when i ask somebody about what they
started doing their art for
but because i'm a dude and i know that
era you did it for [ __ ] like a hundred
percent
i picked up a guitar for [ __ ] i i sang
for [ __ ]
dance i know for a fact half the homies
that danced
did it because they wanted [ __ ] that's
absolutely what it was that's why when i
started first i started b-boying
i'm not even good but why would you do
it it's the most flashy thing that was
happening in the circles what's the
first thing you learned
top rocks no windows
and then what do you do with the first
thing you go into the session you don't
warm up you don't do any foundations you
have no culture you go in there you try
to practice your windows
you bruise yourself you have you have
windmill bruises right here you got
windmill burn
right here and then you kick the floor
right here there's always those hot
spots
and then after that you try to do
freezes because freezes are impressive
so i spent the better half of my
freshman year just learning these like
whack-ass
non-foundational concepts of why i was
trying to dance and the intention was
off but not realizing subconsciously
that
obviously i was falling in love with the
craft at the same time yeah um
fast forward right uh it wasn't until
mike's song
right uh we [ __ ] met oh my god this
is gonna be so
oh i don't know if this is actually out
in any
any digital form so i'm gonna tell this
story it's hilarious okay
so um we have this thing called spot
student parent orientation program it's
for incoming freshmen that go to uci
so before you even start the schooling
you go into like what was at the time a
three-day orientation program where a
bunch of like
staff members who are like actual
members of the school they like walk you
through
not just like a basic orientation of
what's available your options what you
can do
but also just give you a sense of social
life right yeah so they even throw this
[ __ ]
dance spot dance at this at the end of
this three week thing right
there's a spot dance everybody's trying
to like kind of be cool he's incoming
freshmen and stuff like that
and then there's these circles i uh
i i like dance and sucked at it i like
dances like i'm getting all nervous
talking about this story this is so
[ __ ] funny let me drink some more
okay
i [ __ ]
so i go into this circle because music's
playing
uh i think it's get your walk on by
exhibit okay
okay so naturally you've seen this [ __ ]
in the music video so i start trying to
like see walk
this is what this is when like cultural
appropriation just new mentality is just
like fully 100 out there
and then uh suddenly this dude taps me
on the shoulder ferociously i turn
around this angry looking korean face is
staring at me
you know and this is lo and behold this
is mike's song and
i've never [ __ ] battled anybody in my
life oh like
ever i didn't even i've just only seen
the concept of these things
all i know is that no matter what even
if you suck a dance you just don't give
up
you know yeah yeah you go strong that
was like my mentality
so i'm going back at him i have no idea
what i'm doing i don't dance
he's obviously probably whipping my ass
but there's this moment where his shoe
falls off
mid-dance his shoe [ __ ] falls off
right
i don't know battle culture i don't
think in my mind naturally
let me pick up this prop and use it
against him you have to pick up
the shoe and use it as a telephone like
everybody did exactly but i didn't have
that
in my mind so i only had to my intention
let me pick up the shoe and give it back
to him oh
no okay yeah but he had in his mind this
was going to use my prop against me
so angry mike's on korean face comes
over as i'm going to take it down
pick it up and he kicks his own shoe out
the circle
and i'm [ __ ] confused it's like why
would you do something because i
so that was literally the first time i
ever met mike song it was the most like
powerful human experience for like a
non-dancer
like myself to just get like [ __ ]
battled by mike and he kicks his shoe
away so my confusion just like left with
me that day
uh and that was just how that is [ __ ]
hilarious you know that
dance battle culture is so interesting
because it's it's weird how in in the
90s when
um or 90s early 2000s more for us like
when people saw dance they they had a
couple of perceptions of it right it was
number one if you danced you're like
this weak ass quote unquote what they
used to say back and then gay dude
but how orig like originated was gang
member [ __ ]
you know what i mean and so they would
express themselves through dance instead
of [ __ ] fighting and killing each
other
you know which was a really positive
outlet but it's weird how that that
shifts constantly right and it went from
that and now how dance has transformed
now
literally everybody's dancing like it's
it's kind of weird when i see
some of these younger kids and how good
they are dance is like the new jogging
yeah you remember how um jogging back
back in the day with jogging like phil
knight wrote this to nike um
uh maybe it was bill bauerman anyways
point is back in the day
like if you were running down the street
you
had to be in an emergency like yeah only
insane people were running for
recreation
but there was this like transcendent
period where a bunch of like athletes
right who were like running full time
suddenly they like stopped putting their
body through such
physical conditioning so when they got
old they actually would
have repercussions to that so then there
was the invention
of jogging and suddenly everybody who
like you know needed to just kind of run
but not with
intention to like get somewhere a to b
but just to do it for exercise this
thing got birthed
and then literally like a hive mentality
of human beings throughout the world
suddenly jogging
existed i feel like we're in this really
weird
really weird time where dancing is kind
of like that because if you think about
it like nowadays
i go down the street and i'll randomly
see like
every type of person shooting like a
tick tock video yeah they'll just post
their phone up they'll be at like the
target they'll be at like this place
they'll be
in every human being condition there's
some sort of ability to like
do some sort of tick-tock dance you know
what i'm saying and it's like suddenly
all these people who have no idea what
dance really is
have this weird digital foundation no
knowledge
but totally a culture you know what i'm
saying it's almost odd now
word if you don't know how to dance you
are the odd person out
because before it was like oh these
people don't dance they don't dance but
if you don't know how to do a certain
popular dance
like a shoot yeah if you don't do the
shoot if you don't know how to do
[ __ ] backpack kids look you know what
i'm saying it's like you're the weird
guy
exactly so when i when i see how much
it's evolved like
it it kind of blows my mind like i i
just tic talk was one of those platforms
too that really took that that common
person dance and made it really
accessible to everybody right anybody
can be popular through
through dance now and i think like the
weird part i had a conversation with
some
some other dancers recently where they
kind of hate and they love it
they hate the fact that they love the
fact that you know dance is becoming
more accessible people
can see a viable future in in dance like
in terms of a career and making money
but at the same time they have this this
little small part of them is like
i went through i do dance courses
classes i'm traditionally trained
and no matter what i do these kids who
just do this one tick tock video
they'll book more gigs they'll have a
lot more notoriety than me even though
i am a better [ __ ] dancer well it's
different right
like for those professional dancers to
give themselves some sort of concept of
mental health i guess
it's like those people are getting jobs
opportunities are being booked for like
a totally different reason
it's not for them to like showcase art
or to like educate on the culture it's
to
influence a mass group of people a
younger group of people yeah period
you know what i'm saying which is
there's nothing wrong with that that's
sick if i was
so popular that'd be great yeah yeah
yeah yeah but
um from like a dancer's point of view uh
maybe i'm optimistic i feel like there's
a singularity moment that's like
on like coming up it's like
it's like that moment where enough of
the world through things like tick tock
suddenly have enough of a foundation of
movement
and enough of an understanding of things
where it's like you realize
what it takes to suddenly be pro and
then you're like oh [ __ ] and then you
recognize
people who are pro and then you're like
oh that's the difference
because right now the way that i see it
people who are [ __ ] professional
dancers or choreographers people my crew
people like whatever
everybody's at such an advanced level
that the mass general
earth human being population like it
goes over their head over their head
yeah it's right over their head you can
tone down 50 percent and maybe that's
when it gets translatable
yeah yeah yeah that then you can be oh
that's the catchy k-pop move that's the
whatever right yeah
so like conceptually talent-wise we're
already way the [ __ ] above
the mass general population therefore
once that general population suddenly
comes to a certain place where like
they've got enough tick-tock dances in
them that they're like
all right well what does it take to be
even better they're going to recognize
better and be like oh [ __ ]
yeah that's the difference that's in i
believe optimistically in those moments
that's when you're going to start seeing
things like
dance on espn dance ambassador is
getting sponsorships with major
athletic footwear companies or whatever
dance spots on tv
not because it's just selling a brand
but rather selling the culture
itself um you know even the the way that
the
us looks at different sports they can
potentially look at dancing that way
you know what i'm saying like the whole
dance competition phase was nuts to me
just watching uh like the onslaught of
abdc
and how that had a ripple effect on
everybody else that was huge it was such
a huge moment specifically for asian
americans too
because i remember lis watching that and
people saying yo asian people can dance
and i'm like
dance level asian was the trending
twitter concept at the time
yeah yeah i was like yo that's that's
nuts that i think is because
because i grew up around such a lot of
asian people that did dance they were
b-boys and then we had in our high
school we had a group called masterpiece
that's where phil came out of you know
phil tayak from jabbawockeez and all
these other people
so dancing to asian people asian people
dancing wasn't a foreign concept
but i sometimes forget that we live in a
bubble yes televised
yeah in america that was a foreign
concept because at that time you only
had like
two asian dudes that were really killing
the industry it was like jd mcelroy and
harry shum jr
yeah yeah yeah like straight up you'd be
like that's who's that haitian guy you
got served yeah unless you were watching
[ __ ] what's it called uh
battle of the year right then you had
bionic on that but by that point you
were already paying attention you are in
the dance
culture we're talking about like mass
media we're talking about influencing
people at a way that like
like the way that basketball influences
people you know what i'm saying
to watch that show it was called dance
360. absolutely ben was on it
oh was he you don't [ __ ] remember i
never remember being honest was on it
that was you talking about like tag you
man
[Music]
yeah yo that [ __ ] was so fun do i
remember watching on my little tube tv
in my parents stream i was like
my rtv was this big yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's been chung
that's [ __ ] that's sick yeah those
are like those small little glimpses
where i saw people
uh seeing how marketable dance can be
right
and then when jabbawockeez won abdc all
these other dance shows started popping
up they're like yo this is a really
great concept people love dance people
love seeing this [ __ ] absolutely and
it's an art form too that i feel like
a lot of people can appreciate it
without having to actually do it
you know i think sports can be sometimes
a little polarizing because like if you
don't get it you don't get it but with
dance i feel like culturally it's so
embedded in everybody's culture
anybody can appreciate dance everybody's
culture has some
sort of dance that they did even when
you see little kids when they're younger
they just start dancing for no [ __ ]
reason
yeah so when people can see that on a
big stage
it translates it's entertaining no
matter what that's why you could go to
vegas you go to cirque du soleil you go
to any of these shows
you see somebody dance it connects to
you somehow and i honestly i
i thank god for the jabberwockies during
their time you know what i mean like
maybe i would say the generation right
before was like the electric boogaloos
right because they also had a show in
vegas you know and all the eb's were
like living out there
doing like vegas shows and whatnot but
the thing is we didn't have things like
social media
or like mass-market tv shows like abdc
or anything at the time so like the
way for dance to really transcend and
connect with a lot of people
like um they they could do that with
things like soul train more than maybe
like the the vegas shows back then
because we didn't have a way to share
that
yeah and luckily like our generation had
people like the jab walkies
who could even take like the faceless
brand so that
anybody from all walks of life could
appreciate what they were doing
in terms of just dance that [ __ ] was so
next level man absolutely it still is
one of the greatest brands in the world
yeah personal opinion you know it's
weird because like when i when i see
some of that stuff because i grew up
with phil right so we grew up in
sacramento together like one of his
closest friends is my manager abe
and just just watching that and i see
little
when when phil was dancing like nobody
really did what he was doing
you know what i mean and i think like
phil and then obviously a lot of the
members they they were like innovators
or from what i saw from when i was a kid
you know
and then i see like little glimpses of
what they do
everywhere now and it's and it's odd you
know i'm like oh [ __ ]
because i would have never thought that
they would have had such an influence
on just just group dancing in general
and specifically in choreography when it
came to hip-hop choreography right
and obviously people have taken what
they've done and they've leveled it up
in in their own way and now you see
um just an evolution and dance and i
it's real because i saw that when i was
a little kid
just watching them do what they do right
and it's i think that's like the beauty
of what social media has done it's
allowed people to
access something they didn't have access
to before like the other day
i saw this clip with this dude in africa
just doing a show like in his village
and this [ __ ] got air flares
he's doing [ __ ] chair flares all
these weird this weird next level [ __ ]
that that person would have never would
have never seen if it wasn't for like
social media
and youtube and the internet and now
he's doing something in his own way
that he adapted from what he saw online
it's [ __ ] nuts
dude there's a lot of there's a lot of
what's the almost least sensitive way
no i'm just kidding um there's a lot of
for example like oh geez you know what i
mean people that like uh
really totally paved the way for the
culture
but didn't necessarily get to capitalize
on like social media at its boom
yeah and they're like they're like
fathers and like mothers like parents
you know they're not really about like
let me get my social media on and stuff
like that
and so there's like such a discrepancy
from like
the now millions of people probably
around the world that have like been
educated through digital social media
like within
a fingers reach of like searching for
content and
not necessarily like digesting like the
culture the history the intention the
purpose the
the the social and civil rights
movements for which these uh cultures
were birthed
the name and the vernacular for which to
respect the
culture and and how to categorize things
now it's just a melting pot of [ __ ]
people get inspired by
on the internet as fast as they can
receive content
and now we're suddenly in this like
like uh the the people that are the
forefathers
and truly the founding fathers of
culture almost have like
no grip and grasp on
how big of something that they've like
cultivated yeah you know what i'm saying
there's this huge divide now
and so like we're just in the middle of
this really unique
generation where like it's just it's
like a virus
right the way social media is dance has
just gone so [ __ ] far out now
that people are doing things like
remember the harlem shake yeah remember
when they [ __ ] renamed the harlem
shake
yeah everybody had a harlem shake
and then it just suddenly turned into go
ape [ __ ] in costumes in random
in places around the world yeah and
whoever goes the most ape [ __ ] from the
most like non
that's the harlem shake and that's just
it the whole world knows that now
yeah and still only the dancers who knew
the harlem shake for what it was
know the harlem shake for what it is
yeah that's it
that's crazy just this is how it that
information transfers and sometimes
sometimes it dilutes but you totally
done it it's [ __ ] crazy like the the
origin to where things go from now
and i was watching a couple of clips
just the other day of just it was like
this comparison of
of a lot of b-boy moves that were from
like
back in the day yeah before like hip-hop
was even born exactly absolutely they
studied that from this form of dance and
they adapted into hip-hop culture
and i would i would have never [ __ ]
known if it wasn't for that video
i'm like how the [ __ ] is that even a
thing
you know because i thought it originated
from somebody who created that from just
the b-boy perspective in general well to
be fair
there's also the thematic that like
it is possible and practical
for two people to come up with the exact
same thing without influence of each
other
at the same time yeah it's very possible
you can't have like seven plus
billion people in the world yeah yeah
yeah and not have people do
so like even the way that this is a
[ __ ] up concept to talk about
even the way that history is recorded as
we can even see
in terms of like you know the light of
like uh our
our even national history you know what
i'm saying how things are being brought
to light and different perspectives and
the propaganda and the way that things
have blah blah right history in general
is always recorded to
the loudest microphone with the most
followers yeah yeah yeah
like that's that's like the real truth
right
there's real truth and then there's this
person who has like billions of
followers and then they say what their
truth is
and then that becomes historically most
referenced or true
that happens a lot with uh with stand-up
too so like a stand-up comment
they'll make a joke and it's happened to
me before too where i've literally made
a joke on stage and
oh that's somebody else's joke i'm like
how is that somebody else's joke when
that's a story about my personal life
like how but it's just there's parallels
right yeah like if you if you're an
asian american and you make
a joke about your asian american parents
there's probably another asian american
comic that'll
have a joke that's very similar in that
sense you know i think the leeway
between that is
is how it's delivered so if the delivery
is different you could usually tell when
it's not but sometimes even for me when
i would make a joke i would just be like
[ __ ] it i'll trash that joke then
like if you're that stuck on it you're
saying that it's your joke which it
wasn't that great of a joke in the first
place i'll trash it
because your intention isn't to [ __ ]
give negative vibes or weird [ __ ]
exactly
your intention is go out there share
your personal experience and really
entertain people right
yeah and i've seen jokes too that bobby
lee has done uh obviously he did it
before me he's older and when i wrote a
joke i thought it was like a really fun
original idea
but he had one that was i say like 70
similar and i'm like i'm trashing this
joke like
he already did it better so what's the
whole point it's because he's a korean
american and he grew up just like me
so it's very similar stories so i just
had to be you know whatever
i could only assume that that's got to
be a theme
yeah in every industry it has to be you
know music
architecture fashion like whatever yeah
that's got to be a theme um which is why
it's like
i think perspective on how you choose to
like receive or experience
that theme dictates a lot about either
who you are as a person or like how
you're going to walk your life
you know what i'm saying like there's
we we can be called for example like
biters or like maybe we can like have
copied or
gotten inspiration from uh people and
then in retrospect
other people also totally bite us and
have and pull inspiration from us that's
like one
life to live i'm like i am a biter and i
have been bitten
yeah right yeah yeah and then another
perspective to live is like
this is what cultural influence looks
like for sure i mean there's
i think i'm starting to understand too
especially
in how this space works now it's going
to happen a lot faster and a lot more
frequent
um there it's very easy for people to
become popular off of things so if
somebody is craving attention to
popularity
they're going to go ahead and bite the
thing that they know is going to get
them there
because they don't have the ability to
create something like that themselves
some people yes so it's just going to
happen right i think a majority of
people when we talk about a pool of
talent
there's there's a reason why people who
are innovators and who are really really
talented it's like
two percent of this world the other 98
they don't really have that
and you'll see that a lot in in this
creative space because they'll do that
one trick that they stole from somebody
else and people get tired of it you have
to do a new one
and they're fresh out it's because you
already stole something once and you now
you have to steal something else
so but now i've gotten to understand
where it's just like you know what this
is just is what it is
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare if you have a hobby a side
hustle or passion that you want to get
into but you don't know where to start
you need to sign up to skillshare
one of the things i hate is hunting for
information
all over the place because you don't
know where to start so why do that
the more time you spend doing that bs
the less time you have to get
your learn on it's a waste skillshare
has all the courses and info you need in
one place
no more hunting through youtube for
hours looking for quick lessons
skillshare has a community of millions
where you can learn from get started on
your passions
and your side hustles baby look right
now i am taking the productivity master
class because your boy is trash when it
comes to utilizing my time
i suck at it and this course has
definitely helped me realize how much
time i waste
on some bs so explore your creativity at
skillshare.comgb
and the first thousand people to use our
link will get a free trial of skillshare
premium
membership receive free access to
thousands of classes for a limited time
be one of the first thousand to sign up
at skillshare.com
gb they literally repurpose one of
barton joe's jokes or
skip sketches but then i've understood
now it's like well we put this out and
influence somebody so who are we to say
yeah and that's never gonna not happen
for the rest of
eternity considering the way that human
experience is now
like able to be like so quickly
accessible through like
and it's perfectly fine too like they i
mean that's what we did it for anyways
right we wanted people to find it funny
we wanted to be relatable
and if they thought about recycling that
joke and it works for them it is what it
is
i just have to be better and think of
something else hey people are
like this is something that yeah this
i'm [ __ ] loving this conversation by
the way because this is something i also
am coming to terms with maturing my
understanding on
at the same time because we have to deal
with this [ __ ] in the idea of artistry
and the entire
even the artistic path like what it
means to like build a career
chasing what you love you know what i'm
saying like there's no two roads are the
same way but at the same time
if the person before you is doing an
unchartered
road and then you are doing a different
but uncharted road
both of you are doing unchartered roads
now you're doing the same thing
you know what i'm saying so there's
always going to be parallels in like the
experience and the journey
and in today's world really coming to
terms with the idea that like
you might try something you might put
something out somebody else is maybe
going to get
way more successful for doing the exact
same thing yeah that's
normal because maybe you gotta also
count the times that
somebody else tried exactly what you're
doing and you got success outfit yeah
cause i know for a fact there's people
that are trying to do what i'm doing
and i'm way better at it and at the same
time i'm trying to do what other people
are doing and they're way better at it
it's normal it's always going to happen
and i think like people just being okay
with that or understanding that
earlier makes the journey way just more
fun it's not going to change [ __ ]
it's outside of your perception right i
mean it's a huge ego thing that i see
with a lot of people who are
already established right and this is
like me having a conversation with
myself too
because a lot of the times too and i
used to do this like when i was way
younger
i used to feel that somebody else's
success took away from my own so
if i'm doing something that i feel that
i technically am better at that i should
be recognized for when i see somebody
else successful
there was this little part of me when i
was younger that was like you don't
deserve that i deserve that
that's hella real yes you know that's
hella real you try to bring somebody
else down
so they can be at your level you know
and then it makes you feel better and i
see that a lot and
this can go even deeper in friendships
like have you ever had a situation when
you were growing up
and then you had a friend who you knew
somebody who when you started popping
off or whatever right and they had a
conversation like oh anthony's changed
or anthony's done this this and that
it's like
no i'm growing you just chose not to
come with me but a lot of the times even
with certain people who don't wish well
on your success they only feel happy for
you when you're at the same level as
them
unless we're here and we're peers in our
career our money everything else that
you and i can't be friends because now
you're quote unquote better than me
and that's what happens in a lot of
artistry too you're okay with that other
kid
praising you saying you're dope but once
that kid who praises you gets better
than you then you're like
what the [ __ ] like why do you why do you
why do you praise him i'm the one that
taught him how to do this [ __ ]
and that's that ego thing that a lot of
us have trouble with because
we we want to bring somebody down
instead of really congratulating them
because it's we're trying to protect
ourselves
you know absolutely and i'll be i'll be
you know
easier to say in your 30s but i'll
definitely be quick to admit like
i have an ego you know what i mean i
still have an ego
i still have ins like little ass
insecurities
that turn into grown man action that
like really is something that like later
on i'm gonna have
slight remorse over you know saying like
that's i feel like that's the human
experience and being able to even accept
that about yourself is like something
that like people should be okay with
doing so that they can check themselves
quicker
is all you know what i'm saying like i'm
going to slip up all the time too tilt
your mic a little more down towards your
mouth
tilt it yeah yeah i mean it's
that's like some [ __ ] that i always have
to like remind myself of i don't do it
i don't think i do it anymore but when i
was younger it was a big problem like
even like when i uh
got into youtube right when i first
started doing youtube uh
i was a stand-up comic first so when
people would refer to me as a youtuber
it used to
[ __ ] make me mad it would make me
live it and it wasn't an
insult most of the time it wasn't comics
would use that as an insult towards me
when i when i was younger when i first
started doing this is like 10 this is
like 10 i'm not feeling guilty because
i'm like
you as a youtuber yeah so like right so
it's like when i started doing this
it was like i i was doing standup since
i was 16 years old so when i started
doing youtube i was like what 24.
so i've already put in so much work in
and um
i told the story on the podcast but i
remember when i did this event it was
for it was a stand-up comedy show and
they asked me to do stand-up
and i think the reason why they invited
me out to do stand-up was they wanted to
see me
bomb right because i'm a youtuber and
you don't see youtubers
because at the time people thought well
youtube comedy isn't real comedy it's
it's this other realm you get to do jump
cuts
let's see how well you do on a stage and
so what they kind of put me out for what
i kind of realized after after looking
at everything and kind of like the
behavior that they had towards me
and uh it was that oh they wanted to see
me bomb but what they didn't know i've
been doing stand-up at that point for
eight
years starting since i was 16. so i'm
like this is not an uncomfortable stage
for me
but you don't know that and so when they
put out the flyer it said
x-name stand-up comic x-name stand-up
comic and i was one of the headliners
and they didn't put standard comment
they put youtuber
and i'm like that's very weird and very
intentional
you know and but they had me out there
to be a stand-up comic
and so when i went out there i [ __ ]
smashed i killed it but then afterwards
they respected me but they had the
intent
of trying to take something from me
because it was that same thing of their
ego
of like i've been a stan comic for 10
plus years
this kid has did you to the one [ __ ]
famous youtube video why does he get to
be more popular and get to headline
this event when i've been doing stand up
longer i should be known better known
for more so
even like the older generation had to
deal with their ego when youtubers
started coming in
but they weren't quick enough to work on
this platform and
utilize it to their advantage because
they didn't know i started in stand-up
i just decided to use this platform for
my stand-up they just didn't know that
background for it
it's just so ironic because like
i could totally share similar themes
with that like upbringing of like what
it is that got us to where we are
but it's so funny now to at least be old
enough to recognize
it happening again because it's cycle
right yeah now there's those kids
dancing on tick tock they got like 30
million followers and they don't like
dance dance they just like dance
yeah but i'm like i looked at and i'm
like
well i missed the ball like
i can't see it yeah you know i like
trying to just tic talk videos and i'm
like
it ain't me like i want to miss this one
even though i know it's supposed to be
good you should but like
[ __ ] off you do what you want to do you
know i did one tip
the first tick that i put up it got
taken down for a [ __ ] sexual
misconduct and it was just me shirtless
i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
wait it's because i'm i'm making fun of
people right but
i i don't know why but it said it was
inappropriate like adult content
i'm like this video right now and so i
well you can't i want to see this
softcore porn
so i i wrote the uh you're supposed to
petition to have it uh
yeah to put it back up and i was like
you guys are all
fat shamers i was like i'm a man with
male breasts
you need to put my video back up oh my
gosh it still hasn't been up so
i've given up on tick-tock after one
video
they don't want me on any platform
instagram is taking down so much of my
[ __ ]
i'm like oh this is this is weird that's
why i like podcasts i can say where the
[ __ ] i want
this is true but like it's just it's
cyclical it's always going to happen
you know what i mean like i imagine you
go back in time
and [ __ ] the first time they had like
the printing press
and then somebody finally got there
y'all [ __ ] read yeah i mean
like
we tell stories by fire cuz yeah imagine
the first like
taylor who got his advertisement
advertisement
at burton right in the printing press
for the first time and suddenly like he
had business
but then like the generation before him
who like invented this version of
tailoring was like what the [ __ ] like
you want the source you come here this
person jackman that's gonna happen
with the next app after tick tock
there's gonna be something else that's
gonna change the game
and then like you know that's just how
it is the human experience i like
forever whoever's out there including
myself i think is who we're talking to
i think the hard part for me now man
it's just trying to make sure that i
don't stay
content right and for me personally i've
already achieved more than i thought i
was going to achieve so now everything
is a bonus
so now i'm always looking for like next
step challenges so somebody asked me
right now
like just straight up they go what more
would you like to accomplish hey what
more would you like to accomplish
nothing really i'm
the thing is you don't want to be
content what else you want to do nothing
absolutely nothing dude
hey let's fill this box up though oh yes
sir like i wanted to do a film i got to
do a film i want to do a podcast i did a
podcast oh which
by the way was called [ __ ] yeah i
watched that whole film that was a good
film
thank you you're a good ass [ __ ]
great friend at the same time perfect
yeah that was like one of those things i
got to accomplish i wanted to do food
things be in the food scene i
you know we franchise the matcha thing
so it's like that that list of personal
wants is slowly going away and now i'm
at a point where i just want to live
happy
so it's it's weird because monetary
gains isn't a huge
uh like motivating factor for me yeah
it's it's it's simply a necessity
yeah it's like it's amazing to an end
for me so if somebody asked me like
don't you want to make a bajillion
dollars
and i've actually tried that once where
i'm like you know what i'm gonna try and
make as much money as possible see if
that makes me happy
and i accumulated a lot of like
financial wealth
but then i was miserable i'm like this
did nothing for me it
literally did nothing for me because i
grew up with nothing so it's like
i i grew up with very minimal [ __ ] like
we grew up really [ __ ] poor
so i was very happy then so my
measurement of happiness had nothing to
do with money
and so but you know when you're poor you
want to buy the [ __ ] that you wanted
when you were younger
you want to buy the [ __ ] that all your
friends have exactly so i got every
[ __ ] jordan you could
imagine yeah you know what i mean that's
when i i caught the tesla i didn't need
the tesla
like i didn't have to have that car at
all which was a dumb purchase at the
time because that car was like damn near
1500 bucks a month you know
and so i spent that i got all the shoes
i got everything and i'm like damn this
[ __ ]
is novel like i i enjoyed it for a
second and then
that that happiness went away like i say
in like the next
month a week maybe two weeks who the
[ __ ] knows and so i made this shift
where i'm like okay
let's try to invest in stuff that you
personally enjoy
instead of this this this these physical
things which is what for you
i think it's just literally doing
whatever the [ __ ] i want
it's literally whatever the [ __ ]
i want the podcast wasn't a financially
viable choice at the time
it just turned out to be better than i
thought it would be
you know i lost a half a million
subscribers when i started this podcast
so you know from the outside looking in
it's like you just made a dumb choice
but it made me happy i'm like i enjoy
doing this
so i'm going to have to pursue stuff
that's going to make me happy longevity
wise
and then even for the the food thing
right i wanted to try food so i said
[ __ ] it let me go ahead and invest into
this software business and see what i
can do with it which is where i'm at
right now baby
so you know all this stuff too
it's it's it's it all happens through
age and time like i would have never
figured this out when i was younger
yeah there's no [ __ ] way you would
have been like yeah i'm going to do a a
matcha franchise
when i'm in my 30s and you're like high
school
which college you want to go to um i
want to start a podcast
and uh i want to do 10 years with jk
news and
yeah and then it was like okay i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna start away
uh kickboxing you know let me try
kickboxing for a second let me see how
much i enjoy and i [ __ ] love it now
i'm getting punched in the face every
[ __ ] week
so this you know a lot of the younger
viewers too they always ask like how do
you
like how are you so solid and knowing
what you want to do who the [ __ ] said
that who the [ __ ] ever told you that i
knew what the [ __ ] i'm doing
nobody knows yo i'm just as lost as you
i just don't complain as much as you
you know i just don't whine as much as
you i accept the chaos
chaos is life i accept it now once you
accept the chaos
things start to become easier to
understand because now when bad things
happen
it that's just life that's normal it is
what it is yeah
like the other day look let me tell you
this so my dog got stolen from me this
month
right and i had to get my dog back i saw
this my bike got jacked actually a
couple days ago which i
just spent an absorbent amount of money
on it got stolen
and then um one of my friends was in the
car with me they're like you know you're
taking this pretty calmly
i'm like well what am i gonna do this is
life like [ __ ] like this is gonna happen
all the time
i was like how would you react they're
like i'd probably be pissed i'd be
[ __ ] angry i'm like but that's a
waste of my time
i might be angry for moments and
glimpses and i do it for humor but when
i'm angry it's quick it's fast and i'm
done with it because i don't have time
to deal with this [ __ ]
i'm too old for this stuff like once
once you once you start to realize how
finite time is you really start to focus
how much
where you use your time and where do you
utilize it because if i'm using just
worrying about [ __ ] that i can't control
the bike is [ __ ] gone if i see that
guy in the middle of street yeah i'll
break his kneecaps but i have to see him
first so i'll just wait for that
yeah and you have to be in a car at
least yeah
so i can catch him if i see him and i'm
standing he's just gonna go by me and
give me the finger
that's my
that's all he hears dude oh you know i
have a question for you actually
oh you know i like i like watching dance
videos right it's just like
i don't watch as much as i used to but
um make sure you subscribe
make sure you subscribe to kendra's i
actually haven't i just watched the
videos and i thumbs down every video
but you know for you guys when you guys
first started because you guys were also
doing the jabberwocky
faceless mass thing were there a lot of
comparisons
to that crew and like how did it make
you guys feel when you guys were trying
to do your own thing and they were
comparing you to somebody else
yeah um i have a i have a totally unique
relationship with that
yeah that's a great question because uh
i feel like a lot of people on interwebs
like to like
do their thing and personally i don't
really care too much people do
what they do you know what i'm saying um
and you experience what you experience
but for me
i have a really unique relationship
because like if none of my guys in the
crew were ever a part of that
organization
sure it'd be like oh man we're trying to
do our thing right
but like in my crew there's like ben
chung and tony tran who are like oh they
were jet blocks
yeah and then on top of that it's like
even before that like
you know mike song and ving and lyle and
all these guys that they were dancing in
the muse ic show
back in the day even for like a short
period time but they were a part of it
um even on top of that in my company
there's guys like lee jay who is like
you know also part of their company and
is like now part of our company
and you know i i love all the guys out
there like i've taken classes from like
kevin brewer he's one of my like you
know idols from when i was younger
like straight up when i was like
starting dance like kb was like one of
my straight up
idols you know and he's been like a
mentor to guys like ving
um and obviously like fee
is like my bro like he's just the dude
he's the homie and then all the super
cool guys that are also a part of like
the shows
they're all famed us we were on the
shows with them on nbc and everything
like that so it's like
we're too connected for me to have
anything but like
just genuine like i hope they're as
successful as possible
yeah they paved the way for a lot of
people um
we've been constantly inspired by them
uh
they've done things and broken barriers
that like
so like if people compare us my first
initial reaction is actual flattery you
even want to put me in the category uh
category with jab waggies
thank you yeah like oh really that's
sure
you know what i'm saying but if you want
to say like oh you guys are biters
because you guys wear masks then
well everybody wear masks now is covered
baby yeah
exactly i don't have like too many
arguments because it really just comes
down to like what
the beef is or their beef is or what
they want from the situation and like
what they want confronted from it you
you know like at the end yeah like you
said uh there was one point where
we were wearing our masks and then it's
like oh you guys are like you know maybe
like fighting or whatever similar and
now everyone in the world wears
the same masses as us yeah people don't
wear jab watches masks out
in covid's season yeah they look [ __ ]
ridiculous
you know what i'm saying so it's like
it's just i don't know like where does
the conversation go
i have inspiration and i and i get
fueled by it period
yeah and and if you give me something
that's going to give me
inspiration even if it's fuel to just
challenge the fact that it's like all
right you want to put me in the same
category
then let me figure out how to best
myself
let me figure out how to be more
different let me figure out how
it's only been inspiration and fuel so
like i could easily be on a record
with no ego and so i thank the jab
walkies you know what i'm saying for
like everything they've done for our
community and culture
and for me personally i've gotten
nothing but inspiration and a lot of
homies
from that crew yeah yeah um but i think
what you want to hear is
let's battle listen i mean
get out you know what i'm saying because
that would be fun yeah not because it
has to say anything about life
i mean you guys are so i mean i think
like stylistically you're so different
though
it's like apples and oranges to me
especially like the the choreography is
just so different
and kind of like what they do i think
you guys obviously
everybody influences each other right
but at the end of the day
like when i look at your guys is just
first of all branding and everything
else you guys are actually very very
[ __ ] different
it's very very different because because
you pay attention and you understand
things yeah
and people that like don't like really
really focus they
maybe see whatever they want to see and
to be honest
i'm still thankful for that whatever
[ __ ] experience anybody has
great yeah you know jabba's [ __ ] dope
and
i think our crew is [ __ ] dope too so
like whatever you know what i'm saying
uh it's just a matter of like
really just being honest with yourself
yeah
i'm totally inspired by them totally but
i also know that we totally have done
many things that they also have never
done respectfully
yeah so [ __ ] you jab and walkies it was
respectful for a second
that's what i was waiting for i'm
kidding
yo respectfully [ __ ] them they're the
truth
they will always be inspiration points
uh you know even the the
the cats on their [ __ ] dope
that kid tj all of them sacramento kid
man all those kids
all the art of technique kids that are
there too you know the ugf kids
with those kids when they were super
[ __ ] young i think they were like six
years old
like back in the day because they were
from sacramento and they were nasty back
then
exactly like beyond beyond nasty like
ahead of their time nasty
and here they are in their time still
nasty
like i got i got nothing
other than uh comp i'm looking this
this [ __ ] photo of jordan right here
compared to the concept
of franchises in a a global organization
that is uh
unofficial yeah the best franchises push
you
yeah we teams you know what i mean
they exist who kind of ca so i remember
talking to
mike i think we both did a show together
or something i forgot what it was but i
had a conversation with him backstage
and this is before ken just started
and he was having a conversation about
you know starting this group with the
with the whole mass thing and it started
with your guys's uh
ombu black ops thing right which we
didn't wear masks so
yeah i think people have to also
understand like the mask is not
our thing yeah as you could tell if if
you
you subscribed
[Laughter]
ninety percent of our dance videos don't
have math
we're just a group of of people artists
brothers homies
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
we're just a group of people yeah and we
just do [ __ ]
um on tv
we wear different variations of masks
and then always in our last episode
what we get kicked off is like when
we're unmasked nobody wants to [ __ ]
see asian people
i guess that's the thing you guys should
just take off the mask and you have your
uh
[ __ ] eyes taped back i'll take you
back you already know we look like that
i want them straight lines the point is
the mask is not our thing
no matter what people want to say what
it is i think our thing
is just this is going to be [ __ ]
cheesy but
we just want to experience it and at the
same time
there's definitely a sub theme of
elevating what it means to be an asian
american
what it means to be an asian in america
we don't have only asians in our crew we
got a black guy we got
here we got a single black guy it is
what it is shout out phil garvin
you know we got two white guys currently
you know what i'm saying but like
that's in the crew our organization
which has like
a clothing company a record label you
know a noodle company or this or that
like
there's there's an eclectic group of
human beings so it just really comes
down to like whatever it is that the
public out there wants to just like
build passion off of i'm down for it i
feel like you guys are the like so
[ __ ] positive man i just one of the
funniest things i used to always hear
about is like dancer beef and that [ __ ]
used to crack me the [ __ ]
that beef is hilarious to me dancer beef
is so [ __ ] funny because
it reminds me of it's like an
actor going on stage right like he's
performing
and his character is the villain and
then there's another actor his character
is the hero
right but then afterwards the hero after
the acting is done that the camera's off
they go and
he beats the other person's ass and he's
like hold on i'm an actor i'm playing a
villain
don't beat me up i didn't actually try
to blow up the world you know what i
mean so when i see these dancers
they start dancing and it's intense
you're on a dance floor right it's
competitive
and then afterwards they still hate them
it's like oh leave it there
this is what it was for but even if
they're still hatred
the farthest it goes is still
to like some [ __ ] cipher somewhere
that to me
is the most beautiful thing about our
culture we're all pillow soft sensitive
gangsters it doesn't matter how hard you
are
it's not what kind of songs you dance or
how many chains you rock or like
who's in your crew whatever the end of
the day you gotta
like dish out your beef with somebody
you're still gonna be like i hope it's a
good dj
i hope he drops the right tracks you
know what i'm saying he's not biased and
[ __ ] like
that's the farthest it goes yeah if
everyone in the [ __ ] world
every [ __ ] major nation or like the
world health organization the cdc to
like [ __ ] the interpol
everybody's in the u.n like it was a
dancer
and had to handle their squabbles
through dance this will be the [ __ ]
funniest utopian society
ever before they fight they had to
strike for 30 minutes like hold on a
second before i beat your ass at this
dancer go
let me do my yoga real quick [ __ ]
they're just like hey you know what like
you guys got to duke it out you guys got
a situation
and it's like hey we're going to bring
in this dj like oh [ __ ] this dj man he
always favors
this social group that would be the most
difficult thing you would endure because
dancers
handle their [ __ ] and it's funny too
it's like even if you don't like the
person if you get into a battle with
them
at the end of the battle you're still
going to be like
ah that [ __ ] was tight yeah you know
like
like we did that you're like nobody gets
hurt
yeah everybody's inspired yeah they're
going to write a whole inspirational
post
on their instagram about it i was pushed
to my limits
i never thought i'd be pushed these
limits before he brought a beast out of
me
people getting people getting real beef
on the street somebody goes home maybe
with like a broken jaw
here there's like a panel of judges that
are like
like that's the worst you're gonna get
that's your humiliation b-boy
b-boy [ __ ] battles were so [ __ ]
hilarious to me sometimes because i
remember this time where i just remember
everybody had a big dick and they would
jizz on somebody's face
that was like the classic battle still
the thing i'm like
god still there damn it this is the [ __ ]
i just gotta come into a [ __ ] battle
and just do that and then walk out
and like just [ __ ] win the whole
thing i'm not gonna lie i used to have
this battle move
uh for internal battles because we
always do maternal battles right and uh
this is this is a standard b-boy move i
don't mean to disrespect
anyone out there this is cocking someone
it's a standard [ __ ] move yeah oftentimes
it's only one-handed
to elicit the uh kind of the nonchalance
of being able to be like haha
and it's always it's always got a curved
index
and a straightened thumb you know what
i'm talking about yes i do you see this
sometimes they just walk up to you and
they just put this at your mouth and
that's the battle move right that's my
dick
i figured everybody does this but ain't
nobody out there
willing to do this and this was like my
thing i would always like
realism yeah i like that i was like this
is where it's at this is how i
handle my [ __ ] normally so it's like if
you wanna you want me to show you my
my [ __ ] boom in your face
and you always and you always get people
no matter what just looking at your dick
for like a second
because it's like this is it you feel
that
you know what i would do i'll go even
step further no don't say it don't say
it i'll start badly i'll start circling
around the [ __ ] right
i'll pretend to get lotion here we go
squeak squeak squeak
lotion up turn on the tv and i would lay
down on the floor
i would have my my [ __ ] cell phone
with one hand like this
like yo what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
and i would just
slowly masturbate real quick i'll look
over the shoulder see if my
fiance is awake and i start masturbating
real fast look over
here yo it's a little too realistic this
is this is what dance battles should
elevate themselves to
you know what i mean like i want to see
some real fantasy yeah people need to
know like art is supposed to be edgy and
it's supposed to trigger people supposed
to make people question [ __ ]
exactly and it has to do it at every
realm you can't just have the [ __ ] pc
stuff
or like the tactful stuff you gotta have
the in between would i do it
no i don't know but it's important
because i guarantee you i would watch it
i would watch it i would appreciate it i
would respect it and
i don't know where i'm going with this
i'm gonna drink some more but the point
is
if everybody was a dancer instead of a
fighter we'd have a very very lovely
world
oh a hundred percent for sure except for
me though i'll probably get banned from
dancing too
so this guy was [ __ ] picking up
kickboxing ah yeah but kickbox is
different i like punching people in the
face
that's different i'm like no kneecaps my
knees are [ __ ] done
just from playing basketball as a fat
ass so like i usually just play ball
like 270 pounds
and you're just doing layups trying to
do these [ __ ] fadeaways
you know i had this saying i don't know
why i'm saying this maybe it's cause
i've been drinking
i just think when i was in high school i
sucked at basketball i loved basketball
i sucked
i've always sucked at it um and
when i was in high school i was like in
summer league
and i just remember i was like this fat
kid
but i didn't know i was a fat kid you
know what i'm talking about the story of
my life that's what i'm talking about i
only found out it was fat two years ago
nobody told me
nobody told me everyone's like dude you
look great you [ __ ] liars
i was walking around fat as [ __ ] my
[ __ ] doctor had to tell me
don't [ __ ] two years ago two years
ago
oh man anyways i remember there was this
one time
where uh there was this other kid it was
ended up being one of my greatest
friends in high school but
his name is michael lee and i remember
one time i didn't like him
as a freshman in summer league and then
uh
you know we were playing ball we were
talking [ __ ] and there was one day we
called me a
fat ass i was like what the [ __ ]
you're fatter than me you fat ass and he
was like
what the [ __ ] okay you're fatter than me
so we get into this high school argument
about who's fat and who turns out
i was the fatter one
and i didn't i didn't know your [ __ ]
mind was blown
right you never had those it's like that
glass shattering moment you look down at
your shirt you have ketchup stains and
cookie crumbs on your stomach
when you realize that you're the fatter
one it's a whole
yeah it's a it's a life-altering event
just had this moment
where you just started having flashes of
you being a really fat person can i get
a
can i get a third serving please is that
me
well this is back then in junior high in
[ __ ]
late 90s you could get a bag of hot
cheetos
cheese dip sauce and a soda for a dollar
25.
yep delicious why the [ __ ] would school
kids
not be fat and especially if you was a
broke kid
because you had to spend a lot more
money to get
healthier stuff which is normal but so
i'm like
to even process what you actually
are and then to [ __ ] figure out how
to grow from it
that is like a huge huge thing that
human beings got to go through at some
point i feel like everybody's got that
whether it's
fatness ugliness idiocracy inadequacy
whatever the [ __ ] it is that people have
for themselves everybody's got to go
through this moment where they have this
breakthrough at least you found out when
you were 13.
14. 14. you found out when you were like
68.
it [ __ ] took me forever dude i was
walking around calling other people fat
my [ __ ] fat [ __ ] oh man it hurts
so bad to think that you're not fat and
then to like realize you're the fat
anyways i was like
i was ridiculously fat though and i had
no idea like i
was huge and nobody told me as a
sophomore i was 5'4
and at the end of my sophomore year i
was 5 10.
same weight the whole time 154 pounds
i was five four at 154 pounds and then
became
510 at 100 i was 154 pounds when i was
three years old
so i have you beat i was a solid 154
easy i have nothing else to drink to
that so i'm just gonna let you i'm gonna
let you beat me in your absolute fatness
i'm slurring my [ __ ] and i'm getting way
more drunk so i don't know where this
conversation or this podcast is going
but if you want more people
fat chambers what you are dude what's
wrong with being fat huh i'm a fat
shamer only because i had to go through
it and i shamed myself
for years you know it's weird with that
with that fat shaming uh
topic because i was a really really big
guy you know and i and i say that i
didn't know i was fat and i'm dead
serious i actually had no idea
um but i became like a poster boy for a
lot of these young kids who are like yo
if you know if david's fat i could be
fat too
the thing is you know you're fat i
did it you know what i mean like what
the [ __ ]
like i was like i'm chubby you know and
i assume that you know all these these
friends that is a
fat concept though i mean like there's a
lot of gray areas
in here honestly i don't know what fat
was right but
you guys will all know this once you
start getting a little older being fat
is not fun anymore because you feel it
you start to feel it and that becomes a
problem right
so uh like when i talk about the subject
sometimes people like
they kind of muddle the conversation
that i'm having with with their own
personal issues they go
well i can be beautiful i never said you
weren't beautiful
nobody said that nobody said you weren't
beautiful nobody said you weren't
you're not worth anything nobody said
that you're less of a human being you're
actually more of a human being
so just kidding but uh you're like
nobody's say having that conversation
that's a personal thing that you're
dealing with when i said that i lost
weight it wasn't because i didn't think
i was beautiful i clearly did
i was still trying to hit on women like
i was [ __ ] you know daniel henny up
in this [ __ ]
but it didn't change the fact that i was
unhealthy i had trouble sleeping
i had sleep apnea my [ __ ] knees were
killing me my back was hurting me
these are the things that i couldn't
avoid and a lot of the times with people
who are
say like oh i feel great when i'm fat
and you know what the reason why is
because
the human body is amazing it's very
adaptable like we'll adapt to our pain
and our discomfort consistently
the moment you start eating better you
start treating your body better
and you feel something better than what
you had before to go back to that it's
very painful
so even now like i i [ __ ] i [ __ ] love
mcdonald's man
[ __ ] you guys in your mcdonald's
sponsorship thank you but yeah thank you
mcdonald's forever
no mcdonald's you you [ __ ]
don't even know this is both the m
and the love so but i know that if i
have
my you know double quarter pounder and
the chicken nuggets tomorrow
most likely i'm gonna have a little
diarrhea
you get diarrhea from mcdonald's ever
since i lost the weight like i've had
trouble oh yeah i understand
that's probably because your diet in
general yeah i just don't eat a lot of
like
hardcore processed foods like i don't
eat a lot of bread i don't understand
this [ __ ] i mean so when i go ham on it
like mind you if i had
five nuggets a burger and a small fry it
might be fine
however when you go ham on mcdonald's
you go ham because it's a cheat day
exactly i go the [ __ ] off i get myself a
filet-o-fish
large fries 20-piece nuggets breakfast
burrito a breakfast sandwich hash browns
a mcflurry
if i'm a little cheeky i'll get a little
bit chicken for dessert is a good word
yeah so this is what happens right so
it's not mcdonald's fault
is the fact that i choose to abuse it
okay you know so
i i know that when i eat like that i'm
gonna have a problem
so ever since i lost that weight and i
started feeling better
from the weight loss it's hard for me to
go backwards because i just
physically feel sick like it sucks
because i'll see like other people eat
fine and then but if i try to eat their
food in
the quantity that i enjoy because it's a
it's an addiction for me like food is an
addiction
uh i won't feel as good as they feel
right so there's no way your boy gonna
have a slice of pizza
one pizza [ __ ] out of here man nobody
has one slice
if you do your cereal you do minimum
half pizza you get the wings and the
ranch on the side or the bread sticks
you're also drinking a two liter for no
reason because it's part of
the entire ordeal [ __ ] pop lock that
[ __ ] off and you're good
ever say
see this he's a fat shamer and also a
dance shamer the [ __ ] is this guy this
is right
this is you can't see me dude don't but
i'll battle you right now i'll take you
out to lunch bro
you take the i'll eat like i just did it
right now it's dinner time number one
i actually just beat you before we even
started beat it off
so you start off with a verbal attack
and then it gets worse after that who
wants
who wants to actually see his full dance
right now oh you i will [ __ ]
i will [ __ ] put it in the comments if
you want to see him dance let me tell
you something eventually
into this space specifically on his
channel once i once i get
to my surgery any of us once i get knee
caps once i get knee caps you're done
son
we'll do sitting battles we'll do
anything that's convenient for him we'll
do battles with mcdonald's in front
of the [ __ ] you pick the dj you pick
them
let me tell you something give me 17
years and i'll [ __ ] your ass up dude
i'll [ __ ] you up give me 17 years to
work i'll drop everything what the [ __ ]
seventeen seventeen laker wins by the
way
17 are you a lakers fan of course you
are are you like celebrating last night
i don't know when this podcast drops but
last night
it's coming out this thursday there it
is so are you happy to sign the latest
one
i'm [ __ ] happy that lakers one during
this year i think of all years i think
it's
i'm happy because of kobe dude
absolutely for kobe out of respect
i'm a lakers fan for sure i've always
been one it's not about
it's been 10 years it's not about lebron
finally did this
after three franchises it's not about of
course those
variables exist but like in a year of
like
consistent struggle every city goes
through it so i don't mean to take
anything away from any other city but
like for kobe
oh man it was a tough year for the whole
world right so it's like
i think for the ladies started kobe dude
he didn't know what was happening he was
like i'm out this [ __ ] i think i think
for
this to happen you gotta at least
respect
the poetry of life there are certain
things that are like poetic you know
what i mean
no but continue [ __ ] you you know you
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
don't not be an artist right now even
stand-up comics are artists all right
everybody respects the poetry in life or
at least
i would like to think that and you can't
have something
so painful
for the whole world and the whole
culture and then not have it come back
around
i see more like uh instagram posts
with like the conceptual kobe's angelic
arm around lebron then i've seen just
like championship laker posts
you know what i mean when i was out in
la last night
by the staples center where there was
like illegal fireworks tear gas and a
bunch of random [ __ ]
it was when thousands of people suddenly
started chanting kobe kobe kobe that it
was like
this wasn't even playing in the
championship team right now
but everybody gathers and galvanizes
their their energy to start
chanting kobe did you cry when kobe
passed away
absolutely i did where were you when you
when you found out
oh man this is a unique thing this is um
technically i signed an nda and i can't
actually acknowledge where i was
in the uniqueness of what makes this
story powerful
even to say that was not the right thing
to say you're gonna have to cut this out
okay well we'll just we'll just leave it
right there well you know i mean that
you didn't tell anything right there but
you were at a very uh important part of
your life when happened because i
a lot of people too when they found out
the whole world stopped like
my when i found out too first of all i'm
a sacramento kings fan so i'm like [ __ ]
lakers all day
oh kobe i understand you kobe as a as an
individual though
right just you know having to watch all
of his interviews and you know that mama
mentality
nope i could never hate kobe as an
individual right he was our he was like
our generation's uh jordan
so for for kobe to just up and pass away
like that
out of nowhere when i found out i
thought it was a joke
specifically well i i cracked up at this
one part when they said that
what's his name [ __ ] uh how about say
rick ross [ __ ] uh what's his name
uh handsome [ __ ] on lakers
during that time oh my god my [ __ ]
geometry teacher loved this [ __ ]
during what time
during their championship season with
kobe and jack era
yes like robert orry glenn rice
uh nick van axel curly hair
curly hair black dude fly skin black
dude curly hair there's a lot of those
you're like come on david
rick fox rick fox there you go yeah
we're with vanessa yeah
so rick fox they said that i think they
said either robert roy or rick fox died
too
and i don't know why somebody just put
pictures oh that's right
it was like robert orry i think it was
it was one of the yeah it was one of
those yeah why the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] [ __ ] said like robert
dory died too and everybody's like
roberto
is dead the roberto is like i'm still
here what the [ __ ] are you guys talking
about but he was suddenly hella relevant
yeah jersey cells were going up through
the roof that's like
so [ __ ] [ __ ] put that [ __ ] out but
i i thought it was a
a practical joke i thought it was a joke
i i was like there's no way
[ __ ] kobe died are you [ __ ] nuts
and then he died and then his daughter
died too
such a terrible moment the day that we
found out kobe died was actually the
10-year anniversary celebration banquet
of the kinjaz
so i had just come back from from china
from working on like a music video
for uh it was jackson wayne at the time
his 100 ways of music handsome handsome
man handsome man
um and we had just come home so we were
about to do this
10-year anniversary banquet since
honorable black ops in 2010 the very
first time ken just got together
it's 20 20 now so we want to do it on
the same day the vibe was thrown 10
years previous right
everybody finds out kobe dies i [ __ ] you
not
when everybody shows up to the bank with
that you mean because we found in the
morning
when everybody shows it to the banquet
the first
nobody nobody talks to each other it's
really awkward people are trickling
nobody's really talking
so the only thing people know how to do
is drink
so everyone literally takes maybe like
in silence
three four five rounds of just like
toasts
of like this this weird like
hey cheers yeah
finally people get drunk so they can
like let go and let loose and try to
enjoy
the idea that we're supposed to
celebrate life but even then
every speech that night at this banquet
somebody's somehow mentioning
in the light of kobe or in the darkness
of this or
you know whatever and and it was just
i hadn't felt this kind of energy since
michael
jackson died you remember when mj died
yes i do because i was pissed because i
bought a ticket to see this [ __ ]
perform at his last [ __ ] tour and he
died
in the old theater in uh um yeah and he
died and i'm like
the [ __ ] i'm like this is it yeah you
want to take this for this is it
i me and my buddy gabo big michael
jackson fans and so we
we that would have been a dream it was a
lot because i was too broke and young to
go see him
so now you know a little older i was
like oh i could afford this [ __ ] i'm
gonna go see this dude
passes away i'm like we both like [ __ ] i
feel like
to me personally when kobe died or mj
died and when kobe died
or and and when 9 11 happened
oh that's right 9 11. those are three
things that i heard kobe bryant to 9 11.
i do for amazing absolutely i do because
those are three instances when i will
always remember where
i was what i was doing what i was
wearing
how i felt where i was in my life
all of that i'll know all of those
things on only those
specific moments who were you wearing
the time kobe died
i was wearing actually i think i was
wearing these pants that's great
these are your kobe pants from now on
these are my coat they're called mama
blacks
my mamas mom blacks my blacks
my mom is black dude these are cool
these are my momma's black shoes these
are your mama's black shoes
this [ __ ] be drinking doggy
pants
literally grabbed the fabric of his
pants
what do you call their shoes this shirt
right here
it's my mama's shirt
[Laughter]
oh
he's grabbed the fabric he's in these
shoes
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] just just make it worse just
pour me some more
okay to make make the whole podcast
worse oh
this is what i want oh
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was too funny took a very
serious moment
oh man but yeah kobe won cheers [ __ ]
kobe passed away it's weird when um when
you have these uh these people who kind
of leave these huge stamps on
on in your life or just people in
general it actually helps me refocus why
i do the things that i do
so it's like isn't it interesting like
when chadwick bozeman passed away
oh that [ __ ] [ __ ] wrecked me man
it wrecked me because of when the the
stories
where he was doing interviews while he
had cancer
he shot like three or four films
while he had cancer he was helping other
kids who were terminally ill patients
without telling them that he was also
terminally ill and helping them go along
with their judges knowing that they're
going to pass away
and when you look at a human being like
that it's like oh [ __ ] it really helps
you refocus why you continue to do what
you do
it helped me get out of my personal
rights that i deal with so it's like i
get to look back at these heroes
and and look at what they do and make
sure it helps me kind of put my life
back on track
that's so important though i think when
people talk about you know why you do
things
i think i wouldn't i probably would
never be as
obsessive as kobe bryant is right
because kobe bryant is an obsessive
human being yeah he is right
i don't think i would ever go to that
but it also helps me feel better in the
things that i'm doing because i'm like
oh i'm not chasing the almighty dollar
i'm chasing stuff that makes me happy to
make sure that i leave a proper stamp in
this world whether it's with this
podcast or
just you know comedy in general it
really did help me to
refocus my life and it sucks that
somebody has to pass away for that to
happen you know
it probably is natural right
that's probably just how everyone before
us who did something substantial with
their life
also evolved as a human being right yeah
some sort of
uh amazing gain and tragic loss
yeah that defined those experiences and
you know how old are you right now i'm
32. i'm 34 right now so
uh mean you're entering the generational
age gap
where everyone's getting [ __ ] married
or having children or dying yeah
straight up which are i i would like to
think
the three most intense human experiences
that our society has has given us yeah
getting [ __ ] married
having a child or death
which is inevitable so your virginity is
another one
not in our art well hopefully not in our
generation for some people
out there losing their videos okay i
think if you're in your
okay i swear to god i'm still
actually don't swear to god that's a lie
i'm
a virgin you're a virgin
please please don't don't yes yes i want
somebody to take my seat i just want you
to know that
your virgin is nothing to be embarrassed
about unless you're 32
and you have a fiance but the point is
we're entering that
that that space where every [ __ ] week
somebody's getting married
or having a kid or passing away
yeah right or you know somebody who
knows somebody who's passing away so
it's like
the second you get into that i feel like
kind of gap in your life
all the little [ __ ] really becomes
little [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and it's like
once you know me once you experience
that it shifts your entire perception
so in the way that you're talking about
how like experiencing
someone's death is the catalyst
that helps you redefine uh
some sort of identity clause or purpose
or whatever the [ __ ]
i just feel like that's like where we're
at in our life right now and for anybody
else who's in that same kind of
adulting space or generation what the
[ __ ] are we
x uh why i think we're millennials
we're millennials we're millennials what
are the fact that people want to hate on
us for
whatever generation that is i just think
it's really really important
to really come to terms and recognize
the power
and respect the power at which our life
experiences are about to shape us
versus get like drowned by them you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah
when they happen um so like just in
general
that's that's the exact reason why like
at the end of the day i'm here
i'm happy to be on this [ __ ] podcast
just talking about whatever the [ __ ] is
important to us because
10 years ago i think the content that
guys like me and you were
like really hype and eager to talk about
or the things that we were trying to
like express ourselves with
is very different from the maturity of
the don't give a [ __ ] attitude that we
may have
in today's episode yeah why especially
as a younger person i didn't have enough
wisdom to talk about [ __ ] i didn't have
enough life experience but we still did
with naivety and ignorance oh for sure i
mean i can understand i
could only put it in the perspective of
what somebody went through
uh at my age or like to our ages
which was very limited which was so
limited compared to everything else that
we've
probably encountered in the last like
six months
of our lives yeah i mean i guess like
for i mean if i could ask you this then
so
what is something that you do now
that's an improvement of what you did
when you were younger
to be completely honest with you and
today like the right right now that
the second you bring that up the first
thing that actually comes to my mind is
acknowledging my wrongs
because before i think that it wasn't so
easy for me to be like oh i made a
mistake on this
let me fix it before i'd be like oh
i made this decision it didn't work out
right but it was
it was sensible because and my ego would
get involved because i thought that
everything that i was doing was just
like righteous because of the cause of
the moment the idealism
and today i think as an older human
being i've been able to recognize
like oh i just didn't know better so
this was not right
being wrong isn't like oh i'm a terrible
human being
i was just wrong you know what i mean
whether it might be
based off things like civil rights
issues
to gender issues to
sexuality issues things that i was just
like
ignorant to or just not perceptive of or
not open to
at those times i'd be like oh [ __ ] yeah
you know like yeah
i didn't understand i was a little naive
therefore you know here's my learning
curve
now as a person who's experiencing
honestly like
crazy or hardships it's a lot easier for
me to be like
i apologize i made a mistake i need to
unlearn what i understand and then to
relearn the right way to do things
and i'm okay with that yeah younger
you're talking about you not wanting to
do
dancing because to do the dancing
because you thought it was you know
quote unquote gay you know which was a
hot word at the time it's like
yeah what a stupid concept how dumb is
that
and you know what i was also afraid to
admit that maybe like five six years ago
and today i can openly say that not
because i'm trying to offend anyone
who's gay
but because i have to like be honest
with how ignorant and naive i was
yeah and to respect people today
i have to acknowledge my naivety you
know what i'm saying so it's like i
think that those are very different
like understandings based off of the
wisdom of age
it has nothing to do with like i'm a
great person or not it's like oh like
i'm learned it because i'm older people
taught me people
showed me better ways you know what i'm
saying so for me definitely i think the
thing
for me is i've learned to be a lot more
uh empathetic
i grew up just zero empathy like i could
give a
[ __ ] less about what somebody else was
going through because i was going
through so much right yeah
i think that happens a lot with people
who kind of grew up with
brokenness and being poor like you're so
worried about like your next meal what's
gonna happen the next day
the last thing you care about is what
somebody else goes through totally but
or you were only focusing on what other
people had and you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so now i've learned because like empathy
has helped me out so i actually found
this [ __ ]
empathy this concept through therapy so
it's like
you know because not everything is i
used to be a very black and white person
right it probably just because i grew up
in a very religious household it didn't
allow me to see the layers within people
right
so if somebody would wrong me i would
just say
that is wrong when i see you outside
yeah
totally totally you not you're not
thinking about like
why did that person do that yeah what
are they going through
and the weird thing is is that what i
found out was that that
having the ability to empathize with
somebody isn't making excuses for them
it's actually allowing you to deal and
manage your emotions
right because when you start to
understand where somebody comes from
they don't have that control over you
now so it's like okay
like for example um it's hard for a lot
of young people when i see a lot of like
asian activism going on right and i i i
enjoy some of it the other stuff i think
people are being ridiculous
for example uh there was uh a post that
somebody put up it was like oh
it was on facebook they wrote this whole
thing where it's like this 80 year old
guy came up to me and
you know he was trying to have a
conversation he started the conversation
with like
hey like what are some good chinese
restaurants he's like oh do you think
you could just ask me about chinese
restaurants because
and i actually had this similar
situation however how that person took
and how i took it was two different
things and when i was asking this person
who was a friend of mine
and then i kind of wrote on the thing i
was like well
what was that person's intent you know
was that person's intent to make fun of
your culture
or was that person a [ __ ] 80 year old
man who grew up in a different
generation than you and he wanted to
create small talk because he wanted
because he enjoyed your presence there's
two different ways that you could see
this
his intent 100 from what you wrote from
this is what you wrote
was for him just to talk to you and have
a conversation but he
did it in the way that he thought was
okay however you took it
his him saying a racist thing towards
you and you basically cursed this dude
out
so how did that open up a conversation
for him to want to know you better as a
human being
you actually did a disservice without
even knowing it because you
lacked empathy you didn't care enough to
say
why is this person asking me this
question did this person ask me this
question because
he knew better and he chose to ignore it
or did he not know any better and he
thought that it would have been a good
segue for a conversation with you
so that's where sometimes like i feel
like people don't understand how great
empathy is as a tool
it helps you navigate through this
situation i mean you got to have
you got to have a wisdom and a life
experience to like be able to perceive
that
and i think that in time people will
understand that
hopefully that's not necessarily like uh
like everybody finds their understanding
of empathy in their own way
whether it's by direct schooling of like
a mentor figure or it's by just
experience of life
in ways that they have wronged someone
you know what i'm saying
i feel like that's the true power of
empathy
yeah you just like those it just makes
your life so much easier
like understanding somebody else's
situation it's it's
because nobody ends up a piece of [ __ ]
just because they're a piece of [ __ ]
there's always something
i gotta pee copy and i'm drunk
but i like this conversation
how do i do that do i pee and come back
pee and come back [ __ ] this pot
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha not all matcha is curated and
created the same
and jun b matcha stands out above the
rest if your matcha isn't a beautiful
shade of jade green and doesn't have an
earthy smooth taste
then you're definitely not having junebe
matcha is not supposed to be bitter the
caffeine boost and health benefits you
get from it are the best
no caffeine jitters and loaded with
antioxidants to get 10 off your first
order
of tins and packets go to junebeshop.com
that's j-u-n-b-i-shop.com and enter code
geniusbrain to get 10 off your first
order
to day get that matcha on baby i don't
know where the flow this podcast is but
i'm having a good ass time so i could
give a [ __ ] and i could drink some more
but i really don't know where you're at
i don't even know if it's still
recording this is it going
i want to stick up for this and when i
finish taking piss
i didn't take my phone but there's
another door that blocks the bathroom
from this like hallway offices so stuck
out there
so i'm just sitting here and all i hear
is i'm like man there's some really loud
people out there
through my [ __ ] phone i was already i
was sorry i hit the point
because i didn't have my phone i had to
come to the realization of acceptance
then i might be here for a long time
until
david figures it out so i was about to
start turning to knock on other offices
to see if they had a key
olympian everybody was [ __ ] close
everybody's office is gone and i was
like
everybody [ __ ] everybody in this space
leaves at like 5 p.m
i was like i was genuine as i i'm a
drunk dude by myself in this hallway
actually just waiting to see what was
happening i just see you outside
just working on some choreo like you
know this smells like a working
choreo right now i'm gonna get more
drunk cheers this
how do you do podcasts like this you got
no stretchy you just get people in here
you just drink
that's exactly what happens [ __ ] this i
don't even know how long we've been
going
we're going for quite a while usually i
mean first guests usually we go a little
longer than normal because we have so
much to catch up on
you know i don't remember what we're
talking about
we're talking about something it was
deep it was deep [ __ ]
we've been talking about a lot of deep
[ __ ] i swear to god but on the very last
deep topic the only thing i could think
about was how much i need to piss
[ __ ] this is my water i'm gonna take it
yes it is
i'm gonna give a [ __ ] right now
that's what i got so in the previous
podcast area it was like a super super
small room i couldn't fit a bar cart
so like i didn't have much space for
alcohol so i got this [ __ ] bar card
and i stalked it the [ __ ] out
i'm i'm i'm buzzed i'll talk [ __ ] right
now you ask me anything i'll [ __ ]
confess [ __ ]
all right perfect i was kidding this is
like the end of the podcast like that's
where it ends
no this is where it continues no
but i do want to say this you guys are
actually coming out with a with a
[ __ ] instant noodle
which is nuts to be legal we can't call
it instant
the reason why let me explain this
officially
instant noodles already cooked which is
why you remember when you were a kid you
would eat instant noodle or whatever you
break off
before you even cook it with water you
just like crunch on it like chips yeah
you can't do that with this because it's
technically raw because it's air dried
and not fried oh oh well you guys is the
healthy [ __ ] right
it's a healthier [ __ ] so 100
plant-based air dried never fried no
preservatives
and it's no preservatives it's [ __ ]
spicy if you put the whole spicy sauce
on it so if you don't want spicy you
want just
uh regular noodles you want to call it
anything bang sauce
and it's just spicy sauce maybe we
should really [ __ ] well it's kind of
noodles so i don't know how to call it
kitchen sauce
and then you bottle the sauce yeah no
because it's spicy you call it bang
sauce and then people buy it you gotta
work on your marketing guy off camera
i'll explain the logistics and
legalities on why it can't be called
that but it's okay
for now yes we will work on our
marketing
what made you guys get into noodles
that's so random
oh man one yes it's random
two if you hella know us there's a
thread
that makes it not random does that make
sense
so i was uh in 2000 2010 10 years ago 10
11 years ago
10 nine years ago 2010 2011 i was
working as a marketing director for a
street clothing brand called collusive
oh okay you remember this yeah yeah yeah
they're super
popular with like huge graphics
uh foil prince was in every metro park
yeah before metro park filed chapter
eleven and one [ __ ]
50 cent was wearing our [ __ ] uh it was
on a bunch of skaters on a bus
dancers everywhere were inclusive it
just became this like huge brand that we
like really infiltrated the dance market
with
and from there
[ __ ] happened and i stopped working
because um like the brand
went into like a different direction i
wanted to pick up dance and wanted to
like try
what it meant to be a dancer uh mike was
on my song was on cop modern and he had
just gone through abdc so he was like
now
traveling the world and teaching it was
a very unique time where like dance was
suddenly like
are you saying you're traveling and
teaching under your own name you're not
like the choreographer or like janet
jackson or performer for like
this huge artist you were just mike song
or you're
just honored so like this whole era of
like
uh just the prominence of dance started
kind of erupting
and uh fast forward ten years
my old boss from collusive who we always
stayed in touch with
like we were just always like connected
we were always friends he's like a
bigger brother and a mentor to both
myself and my song
and a lot of business stuff and life
things in general and we were always
like we got to figure
out how to do business together nothing
happened for like
a decade and finally we got back
together
at a time where he was focusing on food
industry so he had just
migrated from clothing street clothing
industry
to [ __ ] food it's a very very unique
transition
yeah and it took them a couple years to
figure it out
and start smashing the food industry
that's as vague as i'm allowed to be
right now but like he
he created a number of products that
entered a number of stores that did very
very well
and suddenly we had a
companion who is versed in the food
realm something that like as a dance
brand there's no [ __ ] way
we would have ever had an entry point
yeah so but because
i had worked with him and he and the
clothing company collusive had
originally sponsored mike song as a
dancer
we were always just this like trifecta
of friends
that were like one day we'll do business
together
fast forward we're [ __ ] drunk
naturally
sitting at some bar somewhere in the
arts district trying to figure out we're
like oh yeah maybe we should do business
together blah blah blah
i remember i'm about to leave the
meeting right
and then they're like yo what about this
idea so that i am canceling my other
[ __ ] we go to another bar we keep
talking
next thing you know we're trying to
figure out what's the most right thing
for us to do
all of us [ __ ] love noodles
mike is a huge ramen guy i'm a huge fug
guy
grant and i ate for like every week
growing up as like a
culturally chinese vietnamese kid but i
[ __ ] love
i'm do you love her you're changing
vietnamese like your child yeah
exactly yeah exactly how the [ __ ] do you
know that so sacramento has a huge
vietnamese community
absolutely they do so i grew up around
vietnamese people same with san jose
yeah san jose has a bigger community in
sacramento actually yeah
i'm vietnamese food all day dude button
sale all day that's my [ __ ]
on sale all day so point is i [ __ ]
love vietnamese food and fun
so we just started talking about noodles
yeah and then
for him uh for him to even create the
food products that he had created in the
past
um he would it was always an inspiration
point it's like where do we go
and then how to create that so we had
like a michelin star chef
on deck that created his previous food
products and he was alright let's start
making this thing
so naturally we got guys like twinges
from [ __ ] sag
actually yeah who are on the team and
they're vegans
and we have a number of vegans on the
team in general so we're like if we're
gonna make some
we gotta make something plant-based
normally noodles in general are
plant-based right like
egg rice i guess you can consider it's
all plant-based
but when it comes down to it like every
[ __ ] noodle on the market is like
chicken noodle beef noodle shrimp noodle
blah blah blah noodles right so we're
like all right let's just keep a plant
unless you want to add like these crazy
spicy stuff but let's just keep a
plant-based because it makes sense for
our brand
but at the end of the day instead of
just making another noodle let's try to
innovate
let's try to change it up what what do
we want to do with noodles
number one we're like let's make it a
rice substitute that was weird but it
was huge
because we're like instead of just
making noodles that you could eat let's
make it noodles that you eat with
whatever [ __ ] you want to eat instead of
rice
number two we were like
[Music]
let's make it healthy and plant-based
because we're like
a dance athletic brand so it's got to
make sense
and let's make a soupless
so it's just different from everything
else out there all right
that [ __ ] started to hit in a way
within our internal community that like
really motivated us to be like all right
this is the way we're going to do it
we package it all together we call the
kinjabang noodles it was originally
called something else
but i remember being uh on my
anniversary
holiday honeymoon type situation not
honeymoon sorry
let me rephrase that holiday trip with
my girl and
uh i remember getting a call from alex
my partner for bay noodles and he was
like yo what should we call blah blah
there's legal issues with this blah blah
and we're like yo let's call it kenji
bang noodles
because everybody knows kendrick bang we
got a song to kind of bang
we always say kendrick bang and it just
makes sense to call this thing king
james news because it's gonna be banging
it was some basic like fun [ __ ]
and then we put this thing together and
i swear to god when we tasted it
i expected way worse
i just i was like this is my first time
trying to make food
i expected to be an
asian influencer in you know southern
california trying to do some [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i kid you not this [ __ ] is bang
it's [ __ ] good it's
you know i'm gonna get a box of this
[ __ ] it better be talking i'm gonna send
you a whole box
and i'm gonna tell you david if it's not
good i want you to roast me
on your channel i [ __ ] you not if it's
kind of lucky it's very rare that i
dislike any type of noodle package
anything
okay fine who's a harsh credit to you
are your parents harsh critics well the
thing about
like well i know it's not an instant
though but you know packaged noodle
stuff
there's always stuff that's meh and i
want you to [ __ ] find me a harsh
critic and i want you to give them my
noodles
well anybody who is a harsh critic of
[ __ ] instant noodles and a [ __ ]
dweeb
all right these are instant noodles i
just need an actual harsh critic
you okay you and tim do [ __ ] food
[ __ ] all the time
uh here we go let me try this right here
i want you and tim to try it and i want
you to
not be [ __ ] friends with me during
that time
i'm gonna talk [ __ ] about your [ __ ]
parents i'm gonna talk [ __ ] about your
upbringing i'm talking about how your
[ __ ] hand
is
i'm like you're a youtuber you're not a
standard comic and then i want you to
try our neighbors i'm okay with a bigger
youtuber now
back then i was i wanna fat shame you
[Laughter]
the point is i wanna give you every
reason to dislike it i'm pretty sure
it's going to be good
and then i want you to try it because
like i [ __ ] you not
we've gone [ __ ] around the block with
this thing
and i think are you are you plant-based
too
no i was i was i want both vegan and
vegetarian for how did you like that in
my life
vegan was hard as [ __ ] yeah it's very
limited yeah for me particularly it was
really really difficult because i had to
go to china all the time
and in china you can ask for vegetables
and they'll cook it in
pork oil yeah yeah you're [ __ ]
you're like um the only way that you can
get them to understand
vegetarian is not for you to tell them
that you're vegetarian vegan tell them
you're a buddhist monk
exactly yeah you have to tell them
you're a buddhist
monk then they will not put bacon bits
on your cabbage
that's [ __ ] crazy you know exactly
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
everything is cooked in even their meat
some type of larvae
you have to tell them you're a
vegetarian style buddhist
monk for them to understand that meat is
not the thing you need to put with it
but point is we went around the block
to create this thing i'm so curious just
to let you know
uh i eat some type of packaged noodle
at least three times a week and it's
been like that since ever
that's why that's why it's more
important to me
that you [ __ ] moderate your
expectations
and hate on this [ __ ] early game like
that's how often i eat i want you to
hate on kinder bang noodles early games
if you go to a korean supermarket i
guarantee you i've at least tried at
least 80
of them what's your favorite what's your
favorite instant noodle so as of right
now there's a new runner up this is
kamja tangwon this is korean kanji
yeah so kanditang is this is a korean
pork stew pork ribs too that's
very unique they made a ramen version of
it it's also this other one
um it's this um which by the way korean
soups are my favorite soups in the world
feeds the soul
the best in the world and this other one
called this champong lemon
which is like a chinese korean influence
dish is a spicy noodle soup
they they made an instant noodle version
of it from from
super good those are my two top as of
right now classic ones
dogudi and shin lam in black are my on
my other two friends
and then you can't beat the classic uh
the japanese one the um not nishinroh
the uh
not maruchan uh oh my god i'm [ __ ]
forget i eat this [ __ ]
every [ __ ] week it's because i'm
drunk not niching raw at the uh hella
drunk
not maruchan what's the what's the
japanese japanese one
the one that's in a red and white packet
red and white japanese this is the
classic one this is chicken
no asha's taiwanese therefore
it's not non-shim
is that samyang no that's samyang it's
whatever
everybody enjoys i enjoy some people
love samyang something if you guys
time young's whatever it's like but it's
still good their noodles are like hella
thick it's
anyways no goodie you feel like thick
noodles get no goodie nobody is the best
one nobody's good to you
yeah there was a little choppage that's
thrown in there too
japan is really good which one are you
talking about
the just the regular old plain japanese
one
it's it's like bada-chan but it's like
it's not maruchan though but it's the
japanese one yeah i think i feel like i
know she's talking about but it's not
definite
but i eat it every week but indomie
miguel rang is also one of my top
favorites that's like my favorite dry
noodle one
so if you could compete with the indomie
migorang
okay that's the one
that's what i want you to compare it to
that's gonna be a hard one
good but that's how confident you are
that's how confident i am in a product
that's going to hit the market that you
haven't tried before
that's how confident i am in a new
product
how confident i am in a non-established
product
it's hard to say it hasn't hit the
market yet so i don't
i don't want to be that guy who sits
here eating my words
but you know [ __ ] confident in what
we made because it's
[ __ ] good man well you know at the
end of the day when it comes to food
i think what most people forget is that
you have to really enjoy it first
so if it's a product that you really
enjoy
we'll see texture taste
and health david you don't like it i
want you to [ __ ] fat shame me for the
rest of my life but you're not even fat
anymore
i'll get fat let's get fat eating my
noodles for you i would love for you to
be fat i think you as a fat person would
look so stupid
i think you would carry your weight
terribly dude i think you would look
like hot trash
that's like
people that look good fat you would not
be one of them dude you got such a
you got such a minimal forehead space as
a fat person you would look ridiculous
[Laughter]
oh i'm thinking about my depressed years
of my fatness i i
uh if i wasn't feeling if i didn't feel
the the negative repercussions of being
overweight i probably still would be fat
but it turns out being healthier makes
you feel better
yeah i definitely got some interesting
conversations from people like dms of
like
you know like i you know there's nothing
wrong with being fat like i'm like
i guess but health-wise there's a lot of
issues there's a lot of things wrong
in fact like health wise if we're just
talking about health yeah for sure
to be fair really fat people are
pleasing in a different aesthetic way
it's just a matter of health that
becomes an issue at that point
yeah like i always i enjoy watching fat
people do stuff is that weird
we need to stop this podcast like eating
i've been drinking too much we're gonna
stop this podcast right here
subscribe to davidso genius brain
podcast
i'm giving it an outro so i can save and
protect myself i'll give you a [ __ ]
subscribe david says [ __ ] ended right
here period
whole last section
what anthony is trying to say is that
him being in the industry he realizes
there's a bias towards people who are
quote-unquote skinnier but it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're [ __ ] fit
that's all that he's saying we're gonna
end it like that
they can find you can find anthony at
where on instagram
where on instagram can they find you
just follow at kendra's
uh or at underscore anthony lee
underscore where we say
everything that's very politically
correct and we never cross the lines or
boundaries of anything offensive
because this man is the nicest human
being i've ever met in my life
shame anyone and uh david is a perfectly
healthy fine gentleman
that i've always tried to call me fat
i'll tell you something you can live a
day in a fat world you can't [ __ ]
have a podcast where you [ __ ]
get people drunk and then not expect
[ __ ] that doesn't make any sense this is
like
unfair to the enjoy kenji's bang noodle
is going to be coming out
make sure that you cop that i haven't
tasted it yet but because he endorses it
i don't know it's going to be [ __ ]
i'll tell you right now if he doesn't
like it
unsubscribe to him
if he doesn't like the noodles
unsubscribe to his channel if you guys
don't like kendra's bag noodle [ __ ]
unsubscribe to davidson
all right but we'll see you all next
time follow ken just follow everything
else hope you guys enjoyed this podcast
every sundays and thursdays you guys
will see this podcast up
i love you very much and i've made love
to your mother once at least once before
goodbye